and he's kind of like an x-factor with
his team had fallen to the floor
Westbrook's he's robbing the cradle
rocking the cradle again there all sorts
of thoughts on the cheek seems to change
every day this time he's gonna be a
little back down Tribble she gets off
his feet quickly and there's the rock a
baby I think he calls it but he said
after the last game that's when you got
a small on you is he what does that mean
exactly well it's actually when he has a
smaller defender on him it's just you
know a smaller person he used to do the
thing where he would sort of put his
hand on his hips and say hey this guy's
smaller than me this time he just says
hey it's a baby I got a rocking to sleep
he's been rocking a lot of people of
sleep lately now he wants to boost up
Beverly again
[Applause]
[Music]
offensive player who just can't defend
them and Westbrook the game finishes at
the rim
he's rockabyebaby he's putting that baby
to sleep what he's doing to Patrick
Beverley right now Emily just who's a
good defensive player right this can't
keep him in front of them who who can
it's Carter and Russell Westbrook jumper
in front of the Atlanta bench this is
how you answer a lot of the dust-up does
I call it folks
you just stay focused I keep giving the
buckets now Adams on the advance boy
running the offense through Westbrook
trying to go to work on fox trading away
the bank shot the shoes touch they know
that sometimes you have these slow
starts that you have to overcome court
and just gets a little bit more
difficult when Russell Westbrook is
getting all the way through them that's
all gone who can who can get up there -
pumped verticality now Westbrook goes
right at the rim and scores with the
pants [ __ ]
finishes less brunt bounces out the
defender another turnover by Durant
trying to pass the ball again I just
think Katy is just a little too fat too
passive out here he should be
aggressively trying to get score and get
bastards but you look at Russ
takes advantage of the smaller guy they
came to double-team e fact about
patience he was rocking the baby boy
you see rock the baby and everything the
cradle that he had was a big cradle I
wonder if that's because his wife just
had twins a few days ago bigger cradles
you see when your laces two people say
Russ congratulations to rush will have a
Toys R Us good nap toys his wife has
Lance we congratulate her